[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد ما انعدت رئيس تايوان الى
بلادها بعد زياره الى الولايات المتحده
التقت خلالها رئيس الكونجرس حتى اطلقت
الصين مناوراتها العسكريه التي وصفتها
بكين بمناورات التحضير الجدي والحازم
والمستمره منذ ثلاثه ايام حول جزيره
تايوان التي تعتبرها بكين جزءا من اراضيها
وتهدف تلك المناورات بحسب الخارجيه
الصينيه الى تحضير تايبيك من التواطئ بين
القوات الانفصاليه التي تسعى الى استقلال
تايوان والقوى الخارجيه وتشمل محاكاه
ضربات دقيقه مشتركه ضد اهداف رئيسيه لخلق
ردع وتطويق كامل لتايوان وفقا بكين
فالتدريبات التي اسمتها الصين السيف
المشترك نشرت خلالها القوات الجويه
الصينيه عشرات الطائرات لفرض حصار جوي على
الجزيره بمشاركه حامله الطائرات شاندونغ
بينما نفذت قواتها البريه تدريبات على
ضربات دقيقه متعدده الاهداف بالاضافه الى
نشر مدمرات وقذفات صواريخ وزوارق سريعه
قاذفه لصواريخ ومقاتلات واجهزه تشويش
وذكرت المناوره الحاليه او ذكرت بتلك التي
نفذتها الصين في اغسطس الماضي ردا على
زياره النائبه الديمقراطيه لتايوان حيث
كانت تشغل حينها منصبه رئيسه لمجلس النواب
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
طارق الشاميه المحلله السياسي اهلا بك من
بكين الصحفيه
واهلا بكم ضيفاي الكريمين اسمحالي ان ابدا
معك استاذ الشامي في الواقع يقول البعض
بان الصين استقبلت الرئيس التايوانيه
بمناورات ولكن صيني اعتبرتها مناورات
للتحضير الجاد فهل نستقبل الرساله الصينيه
كما هي نحن في اطار التحذير ام ان هناك
شيء يحضر ومنذ فتره من الصين تجاه
تحياتي لك من بكين يعني اعتقد انه ليست
هناك
دوافع امريكيه لاثاره مزيد من القلق او
التوترات مع الصين خصوصا وان احد
المستشارين في البيت الابيض تحدث عن ان
الولايات المتحده لن تستفز وسوف تتعامل
بمنطق رد فعل حكيم وهو ما يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده اتبعت صحيح ان ربما
ضيق بكين وشعورها بالانزعاج من زياره رئيس
التايوان الى
الولايات المتحده ولقائها مع مكارسي
بالاضافه لزياره وفد امريكي ايضا من لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه الى تايوان كل هذا كان
مثيرا للقلق لكن الولايات المتحده لا
تعتقد ان الصين بصدد القيام بعمليه عسكريه
هذا الاطار واشنطن بانها تتابع
التطورات ولكنها تبقى مطمئنه سنعود الى
موقف ورشه ولكن ودت قراءه حضرتك الخاصه
بما يتعلق بنوايا الصين الحقيقيه هذا هو
السؤال
يعني نوايا الصين الحقيقيه هي ارسال رساله
سياسيه وعسكريه بانها قادره على حصار
تايوان ربما لديها عده خيارات احدها حصار
تايوان او القيام بعمليه عسكريه والثالث
يعني ربما يكون
استخدام الوسائل الدبلوماسيه لانهاء
المشكله بان تقبل تايوان الانضمام الى
الصين لكن في كل الاحوال اعتقد انه
الولايات المتحده لا تعتقد ان الصين على
وشك الهجوم او القيام حتى بالحصار في
اللحظه الراهنه بالنظر الى انها يعني تريد
بشكل كبير
اعطاء اشارات لتايوان تحديدا اكثر من
اعطاء الاشاره الى الولايات المتحده بانها
لا يجب ان تنفصل او تقوم بعمليه اعلان
انفصال عن الصين او الاعلان الاستقلال
بمعنى
مره اخرى طيب استاذ طارق اسمح لي ان نسال
كذلك ضيفتنا من بكين في هذا الشان سيده
ياي
تعلمين حضرتك بانه الصين لطالما كانت
لديها تصريحات تعتبر فيها حقا ان
تضم الجزيره الى البر الصيني
دبلوماسيا وهذا فهمناه ولكن لم تستثني
كذلك
القوه قالت بانه بكل الطرق سنحاول سنبدا
دبلوماسيا ولكن كذلك حتى
الطريقه
العسكريه هي وارده لضم الجزيره الى المراه
الصيني هذه المناورات تاتي في اي اطار
ننصحها انا سينا ترتدي دائما بخيار السرمي
لي حقيقه توحيد الكاميرا
منذ اكثر من الفين سنه وحسب القوانين
الدوليه وحسب القانون الوطني الصيني
اعتقد
تلتزم بمبدا الصين واحده التي الذي يعتبر
اساسا سياسيا لدى السينا ولدي
180 دوله التي اقامت العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
مع السين انا من جهه ومن جهه اخرى يجب
علينا ان نعرف ان هذه المناوره وتدريبات
العسكريه جاءت رادن على زياره الرئيس
بمنطقه حيوان صينيه
لقاء لقاء مع رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
وحسب البيانات المشتركه بين الصين
والولايات المتحده لا يمكن
للولايات المتحده ان هي اي تبادلات رسميه
مع منطقه حيوان فقامتها السينا بمثل هذه
المنورات العسكريه غدا على او تمثل تحذيرا
من تواتؤ بين منطقه الحيوان والقوه
الخارجيه التي تريد او تحاول تداخل في
الشؤون الداخليه صينيه
ولكن ما هي حدود الصين التي لن تقبل بها
المزيد من التقارب الامريكي التايواني
بمعنى ان هذه الزيارات مستمره وهناك كذلك
تسليح تقدمها اداره بايدن هناك اسلحه
تقدمها لتايوان منها المعلن ومنها الغير
معلن وبالتالي
ما الذي لن يقبل صينيا وعلى اسره قادره ان
تتحرك
طبعا في مساله تتهوى هناك خط لاحد مره لدى
السيد مهما كانت مع القوه انفصليه وكذلك
مع
الولايات المتحده في العلاقه صينيه
الامريكيه واكدت السينا لمرار ان الولايات
المتحده لا يمكنها ان تستمر في طريقها
الخطا
لدعم الماء يسمى باستقلال الحيوان معتقد
ان القاتل احمر هو يعلان دعم الولايات
المتحده المنطقه تحيوه
لحقيقه او يعلان ما يسمى باستقلال هذيك
المنطقه حسب القانون
وايضا يمكن نلاحظ هذه المناوره هدفها يعني
انا يعني كلما اجتهدت التواتر متساعده بين
منطقه
فن ان المنورات العسكريه الصينيه اصبحت
اقوى فاقوى وفي حادث لما مر المناوره تحيط
كل الجزيره من حيث الاتجاهات المختلفه هذا
يعني ان القوات الصينيه تتمكن تماما من
سيطره على الوضع في اول وقت اذا اندلع اي
صراع العسكري وهذا يمثل تحذيرا شديدا
للقوه الانفصاليه ثوانيه والقوه الخارجيه
ويبدو بان هذا التحذير سيتارق ليس موجهه
فقط لتيوان وموجه كذلك لواشنطن لايف تقول
بانه لاول مره هذه المناورات تطوق من كامل
الجوانب تايوان وكانه هناك رساله كذلك
لواشنطن بانه نحن قادرون على ضم تايوان
ولكننا نفضل الطرق الدبلوماسيه على
العسكريه ما رايك
المناورات هي كانت ربما تكرار لما حدث
حينما زارت بيلوسي في اغسطس الماضي بكين
واعتقد ايضا انها لم تستخدم الصين لم
تستخدم القوى النيرانيه
المماثله مثل ما حصل في اغسطس الماضيه
استخدمت قوى الايرانيه اقل واستخدمت نحو
70 طائره و11 سفينه في الوقت نفسه فان
الولايات المتحده ايضا ارسلت رساله الى
بكين مفادها بان حامله الطائرات الامريكيه
كانت موجوده على بعد نحو 300 ميل تقريبا
من تايوان
لا يعتبر استفزاز امريكي خاصه اذا ما
اضفنا اليه بعض التصريحات الاخرى
الامريكيه يعني واشنطن تقول باننا نتابع
عن كثب ولكن تقول نتابع بارتياح لانه كما
قالت واقتبس من تصريحات بعض المسؤولين
الامريكيين لان لدينا الموارد والقدرات
على الصعيد الاقلي مي لضمان السلام
والاستقرار يعني لاحظ معي بانهم لا
يتحدثون عن ارتياح لثقتهم في الصين هم
يتحدثون عن ارتياح لثقتهم في انفسهم لانهم
متواجدون
بالكيفيه التي تمكنهم من حمايتي وعن هذا
لا يعتبر استفزاز للصين
ربما تعتبره الصين كذلك لكن بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده هو تاكيد على دورها
العالمي في الحفاظ على الاستقرار هي تشعر
بقلق من توسع الصين ليس فقط بشان تايوان
وانما ايضا في بحر الصين الجنوبي والشرقي
وهي اذا نظرنا الى الايام والاشهر الماضيه
كان هناك ايضا اتفاق بين الولايات المتحده
والفلبين على استخدام عدد من القواعد
العسكريه في الفلبين ما يعني ان الولايات
المتحده في طريقها الى تعزيز تواجدها
العسكري وتقوم بالاستعراض القوه العسكريه
ليست بمفردها وانما بالتعاون مع حلفائها
في اليابان وفي كوريا الجنوبيه وفي غيرها
الولايات المتحده لا تريد التصعيد لكنها
في ذات الوقت لا تريد التخلي عن مكانتها
كقوه عالميه رائده وهي تعرف بان الصين
لديها طموحات كبيره وطموحات تعتبرها
واشنطن توسعيه ولذلك فهي تعمل في هذا
الاطار اطار انها لا تريد التصعيد لانه
ليس في الولايات المتحده ولا في مصلحه
الصين التصعيد العسكري لان هذا سيضر
بهذهما على المستوى الاقتصادي والتجاري
وهناك تقارير تقول انه حتى اذا حاصرت
الصين تايوان فان هذا يعني انه ستكون هناك
خساره تصل الى نحو 2 تريليون دولار امريكي
نتيجه لهذا الحصار وسوف يؤدي الى اشتعال
المنطقه والتوترات في المنطقه بالتاكيد
الولايات المتحده تلعب
بطريقين بالعصا والجزر هي تريد ان تقول
انها متواجده عسكريا وان تايوان في مرمى
القوات الامريكيه وتستطيع طائراتها التي
تنطلق من اماكن متعدده ان تصل وتدافع عنها
وهناك تصريح واضح جدا حتى من مايك ماكول
وهو رئيس اللجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في
مجلس النواب الذي قال خلال محادثاتي مع
التايوانيين ان كان دائما مطروح فكره ان
تستخدم قوات امريكيه في الدفاع عن تايوان
اذا الراي العام الامريكي مؤيدا لذلك ايضا
لا ننسى ان الرئيس بايدن تحدث عده مرات
وقال انه لا يستبعد ان تدافع الولايات
المتحده عن تايوان هذا لا يعني الناس
ستفعل ذلك لانه لا توجد اتفاقيه بين
تايوان والولايات المتحده لكن هذا يعني
انه جزء من سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي
الامريكي تجاه فكره الدفاع عن تايوان هي
لا تريد ان تقول سنفعل او لا نفعل لكن
اريد ان تقول للصينيين احذروا هذا ممكن
وهذا يجب ان تاخذوه في طيب ولكن الصين من
جهه اخرى كذلك تضاعف تصريحاتها المحذره
لواشنطن بخصوص عمليه التسليح وهنا سؤال
سيده اذا ما استمرت عمليه التسليح واستمر
التقارب التايواني الامريكي ما الموقف
الصيني المنتظر
موقفها ثابته وواضحه انه في مسارتها ولا
يوجد اي مجال لتنازل بالنسبه للصين مهما
كانت من ضغوطات الامريكيه او من نادغدات
الاخرى لان الصين اكدت ان الشؤون الهواء
يجب عليها ان تقرر فقط من الصين ولا يمكن
لاي قوه لاي احد ان تتداخلوا في شؤون
الداخليه صينيه وخاصه مساله
المحور مساله محوريه
المحلله السياسي شكرا لكما بهذا نصل الى
نهايه بانوراما السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات